now you're worldwide dude I mean your
music I feel like your music was very
like
you know I feel like I learned so much
from your music as a kid because it was
before I really had like readily like
internet access if that makes sense so
like some of the [ __ ] like about like
our government or just the world like I
have first heard like you rapping about
it do you hear that a lot I mean I think
it was during a time in which people
were
um living in a post 9 11 world that was
really fresh and a lot of individuals
were scared they were looking for easy
answers looking for ways to blame people
and when I brought up things like for
example that I made a post today because
it's the 20-year anniversary of Senator
wellstone's uh death in a mysterious
plane crash and he was one of the only
Senators after 9 11 that brought up the
fact that Bin Laden was a CIA asset that
was not something people wanted to
discuss in 2000 right right that is code
name and this is not a conspiracy no
it's not a conspiracy it's true his code
name was Timothy Osmond and that he
carried out several acts and atrocities
in the name of the United States
government for their purposes but not
just that also talking to people in
Afghanistan when I went there he was
responsible and took part in what they
call the hazrat genocide which is
something that is going on now with the
Taliban and that's a series of Asiatic
Central Asian
people from Afghanistan yeah and they
were targeted for genocide so before Bin
Laden ever killed any Americans he
murdered children outside of a city
called mazara Sharif and like I went to
Afghanistan in 2009 to build an
orphanage in a school with the prophets
from uh an album that I had called the
third world with DJ Green Lantern